well I but I want to get your thoughts
on this breaking news brian burke no
longer the president general manager of
the Toronto Maple Leafs well rush me for
full disclosure I know the man I respect
him a lot I like his discipline his
focus and that's probably what got him
in trouble he should be an owner himself
that's what I look at it but he
certainly acted that way and that's good
some ways and running a team but here's
the piers the issue I I would have if I
owned equity in the Leafs here's a team
that represents about 75% of the ebit da
the free cash flow the entire league of
the NHL and they don't even have to win
a game so here's your quandary if you're
forgetting about the sports and the
pride of winning why pay for expensive
players at all you could put on the
worst performance they make the most
cash flow and they are the worst
performers that's the way you look at it
and that's a real interesting quandary
because in some ways you could just put
baby seals out there on the ice with
hockey sticks and make a fortune you
have to pay baby seals anything so I
think there's going to be a new way to
run a team like this because you're
missing here's the cash flow you're
missing and believe me in life it all
boils down to cash and by the way that
strike was all about cash so don't let
anybody tell you this isn't about money
because that's what it is here's what
the Leafs are missing they never make it
to the playoffs there's all those
tickets they never sell in the playoff
series these guys are losers so maybe
the management and the ownership should
be looking at extending in other words
maybe win a couple of games along the
way maybe win some in the later part of
the season when you can they make even
more money because you know the fans are
willing to come and sell it out every
game and that's probably has a little
bit to do with what happened here a
disagreement on what the direction is to
win a couple of games they know how to
lose they're really good at that now
they have to learn how to win but they
don't even have to win they're already
making as much money you think they'd
make more money if they exactly you know
you can sell it every game they always
get kicked out so early this year of
course they're doing great they're
starting right at the top in the middle
of the season so we're right into
playoffs practically so the Leafs have
to figure out a way if you're the owners
how do we stay in the game longer so we
can make more money because I love when
people say no it's the pride of winning
no it's the love of the game that's all
crap
this is about cash flow and they've got
to figure out a way to stay in it longer
to make more money it's that simple it's
also a bit loyalty leaves fans stay
loyal to their team even though they're
not winning I mean it may actually see
Doyle T they love the pain of watching
them lose what's your experience a
you're a Habs fan no you know I'm just
telling you the way it is cuz i go to
leave schemes how are they gonna lose
this time is the question that's what
I'm asking myself as I'm you know
getting my next hot dog you're a birkis
hot dog yeah well basically but look
believe me at the end of the day in all
seriousness it's always about money all
the time and if they can figure out a
way to win even stay in another twenty
percent longer it's a ton more money for
the owners who've just paid up for this
little beast this is an expensive team
but makes seven there's no there's no
other it anywhere else in professional
sports do you find a situation where 75%
of cash flows on one team well the
picture that you paint though makes it
unfortunate for anyone to take that
position as president and GM men have a
team that doesn't want to try to win in
in defense of the you know of this
position it's always gonna be the most
volatile in professional sports when
you're a GM of a team you're gonna get
whacked every 36 months don't worry he's
gonna land somewhere just fine he's a
very good GF maybe as an owner as you're
suggesting maybe I if you were to write
another version of cold hard truth I
know this is your second one right if
you were to write a third one for the
NHL hockey teens owners players
millionaires billionaires what advice
would you give him I'd give them to
focus on the bottom line that they've
really done a great job in trying to fix
the model the players we're making way
too much money and now because they're a
commodity you know that the truth is
people don't talk about it but here's a
fact about hockey the average journeyman
only lasts about 98 games across 36
months and then there's a whole new crop
of young guys coming up why pay them so
much why well I don't understand where
is it written they should make half the
profits I would treat them like they are
their commodities nice guys I'm not
trying to say anything about these
aren't they're wonderful people and all
that but their commodity the owners have
something unique and proprietary they
own the team that's an oligopoly you pay
less for a commodity it's that simple
you